France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe une Europe qui
pourrait bien prendre un coup de bottes
très prochainement après la percée de
l'extrême droite en Suède c'est au tour
de la botte l'Italie en effet d'être
tenté par l'aventure extrémiste frappé
de plein fouet par l'explosion des prix
de l'énergie croulant sous une dette
publique de
2700 milliards d'euros l'Italie se rend
aux urnes le 25 septembre prochain une
coalition du parti post fasciste
Fratelli d'Italia de Georgia Meloni de
la Ligue aussi de Matteo Salvini et de
Forza Italia de Silvio Berlusconi semble
en mesure de conquérir le pouvoir nous
recevons aujourd'hui son principal
opposant le chef du parti démocrate
italien l'ex-président du Conseil Enrico
l'état bonjour monsieur l'Etat un chef
qui croit encore aux chances d'une
coalition de centre gauche pour barrer
la route à l'extrême droite alors
pourquoi après un gouvernement d'union
nationale dirigée par Mario Draghi
est-ce une post fasciste qui prétend
désormais diriger l'Italie comment
est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là
l'Italie depuis beaucoup
dans une tendance qui a une tendance de
peur
électorat qui vote pour des parties
populistes et avec un sentiment d'euros
scepticisme qui a été très fort les
élections de 2018 étaient là pour
démontrer ça et ça a continué ça a été
vraiment une énorme chance celle d'avoir
eu Mario Draghi et son gouvernement dans
un parlement hyper fragmenté pendant la
dernière année et demi et nous nous
avons soutenu ce gouvernement même si
nous et notre ligne pro-européenne avait
perdu les élections de 2018 on se trouve
aujourd'hui à combattre sur une ligne
qui est évidemment dans un dans une
arène qui est très complexe mais je
pense qu'on a beaucoup de raisons pour
chercher le verbe basculer les choses
pour chercher de faire comprendre
c'est-à-dire le grand risque de prendre
la voie de la droite anti-européenne et
la voix de la droite
souverain qui est celle de George
germelon mais alors le grand avantage
justement de cette droite dans
l'élection c'est son unité Silvio au
Berlusconi a fait alliance non seulement
avec la Ligue de Salvini mais aussi avec
les frères d'Italie qui sont crédités de
plus de 20 % des voix cette droite
traditionnelle qui a Adobe la l'extrême
droite c'est hors-jeu pour vous
je pense simplement que le centre droit
italien des
décennies qui ont vu l'Italie et
gouverner pour au moins une
des années une dizaine d'années par la
droite le centre droite aujourd'hui a
complètement changé aujourd'hui il
s'agit d'une droite une droite
anti-européenne la droite qui est en
France à liée avec Marine Le Pen la
droite qui est en Espagne alliée avec
les postes franquistes de Vox la droite
qui est allié en Europe avec Orban le
Hongrois ou le polonais du
donc évidemment il y a eu
une dégringola d'un dérapage vert la
droite extrême en Italie tout ça est lié
aussi à la situation du pays la
situation sociale comme vous disiez
auparavant la guerre de la Russie à
l'Ukraine a fait monter les traits de
l'énergie d'une façon hélas
insupportable on a on vient de deux
années de pandémie avec les peurs qui
ont été lié à ça la perte du pouvoir
d'achat bref cette société inquiète à
des peurs qui comme en Suède aujourd'hui
leur disent que il faut
écouter ceux qui cherchent de souffler
sur cette sur ses peurs nous on dit
exactement le contraire on a des
solutions concrètes et on dit que
l'Europe est la solution parce que
l'Europe ça veut dire des solutions
communes alors que
passer d'une Italie qui compte en Europe
avec Dragui à une Italie qui simplement
proteste en Europe c'est quelque chose
qui va contre les intérêts des Italiens
et des Européens mais d'un certain point
de vue Enrico Letta vous-même vous
auriez pu prétendre à la direction de ce
pays si seulement vous aviez réussi
aussi à faire une coalition parce que
c'est important de faire des coalitions
dans votre système électoral en
particulier avec le mouvement 5 étoiles
pourquoi ça n'a pas marché
ça n'a pas marché et là c'est parce que
le 5 étoiles a décidé de premièrement de
faire chuter draguer et je pense que ça
ça a été le choix le pire le pire des
choix parce que
ça aurait été tout un autre film si on
avait le gouvernement draguer qui
continuait et qui faisait ce qu'il était
nécessaire pour le pays on aurait voté à
l'échéance naturelle au printemps dans
une situation complètement différente là
ça a été incompréhensible le choix du 5
étoiles qui de mon point de vue a voulu
retrouver la virginité initiale qui
s'est perdu pendant ces cinq années car
au gouvernement le 5 étoiles dans cette
législature a gouverner avec tout le
monde avec la droite souverainiste au
début
puis avec nous et avec Dragui évidemment
tout ça a fait en sorte qu'ils sont
chutés dans les sondages et leur choix
d'aller tout seul de faire plutôt un
choix de reprendre leur virginité leur
pureté initiale mais ça veut dire qu'ils
ont choisi de sauver de sauver eux-mêmes
et non pas de sauver le pays nous on a
choisi un autre on a notre direction
nous on a construit une coalition avec
d'autres parties avec le parti de M
abonné non avec les verres avec le parti
de Luigi qui a laissé les 5 étoiles pour
construire la partie et qui est en train
de être en coalition avec nous bref vous
espérez
la première place devant d'ailleurs le
parti des Frères d'Italie mais ça
changerait pas grand chose parce qu'en
fait s'il accède en coalition au pouvoir
ils vont rafler quand même les deux
tiers des sièges c'est un système très
paradoxal le système italien
sur un tiers de siège first passe de
poste dans lequel le premier gagne et
les autres ne passent pas un peu comme
un système français mais seulement au
premier tour et évidemment ce système
fait en sorte que qui gagne avec
beaucoup de marge mais c'est aussi un
système dans lequel un changement un
basculement d'un 5% de voix d'une
coalition à l'autre ce qui aujourd'hui
est possible surtout dans le Sud du pays
on est en train de vivre cette tendance
fait en sorte qu'on peut gagner beaucoup
de collèges qui étaient jusqu'à
maintenant vu comme perdu bref on a des
jours devant nous dans le dans
lesquelles on est en train de combattre
et de faire passer nos idées sur le
travail sur les droits civils sur
l'environnement puisque sur ces sujets
la droite à une approche négationniste
totale elle veut faire revenir en
arrière le pays on va combattre et on va
chercher de faire basculer ce bois et de
convaincre les électeurs italiens alors
je le disais votre principal adversaire
c'est Georgia Meloni 45 ans ancienne
ministre de la Jeunesse de Silvio
Berlusconi la fait sécession de ce parti
en 2014 pour fonder le Parti national
conservateur des frères d'Italie
italienne mère chrétiennes c'est comme
ça qu'elle se définit en s'efforçant
d'ailleurs de dédiaboliser son image
elle essaie d'ailleurs de rassurer aussi
les européens en particulier sur Twitter
où elle a publié une vidéo en français
anglais espagnol on écoute un extrait en
français
j'ai lu que la victoire de Fratelli
d'Italia aux élections de ce timbres
conduirait en désastre en tournant
autoritaire à la sortie de l'Italie de
l'Hérault et à d'autres absurdités de ce
genre rien de tout cela n'est vrai mais
je sais très bien que ces articles sont
inspirés par les bouchons sur toutes
médiatiques de la gauche il a également
été dit qu'un gouvernement de sainte
droite mettrait en danger le fond de
Rouen tout next
generational de relance de résilience
mais je demande
catégoriquement c'est narratif absurde
sur ces terrains les gouvernements
dragués auraient pu faire plus mais il
n'y a pour faire non pas à cause de
Fratelli d'Italia le seul parti
d'opposition mais à cause du majorité
trop hétérogène et querelles
voilà on doit être pleinement
rassuré pleinement rassuré c'est le cas
c'est le cas en fait
aujourd'hui
elle assure qu'il n'y aura pas de
rupture sèche alors que Rome est la
principale bénéficiaire du plan de
relance avec 200 milliards d'euros de
fonds accordés pour maintenir à flot la
troisième économie de la zone euro
notre campagne est basée exactement sur
ce point un des points centraux l'idée
que l'Italie est devenu avec Mario
Draghi un des moteurs de l'intégration
européenne ça a aidé l'Europe à trouver
des solutions
l'Italie en Europe pour nous c'est la
photo du train pour qui elle dans
laquelle vous aviez ensemble Emmanuel
Macron olafe et Mario Draghi ça c'est
l'Europe et ça c'est la place de
l'Italie en Europe évidemment ce n'est
pas le cas avec Mélodie son idée est une
idée de Europe comme Ligue des Nations
dans lesquelles chaque pays joue pour
lui-même dans lequel les décisions sont
prises à l'unanimité avec le droit de
veto comme
urban veut ou comme Marine Le Pen veux
une idée d'Europe dangereuse de mon
point de vue parce que
l'Italie de Draghi notre Italie l'Italie
du Parti démocrate et en Europe comme
moteur de l'intégration européenne
et l'Italie de Georges jameloni de la
droite italienne de Salvini serait en
Europe comme frein de la intégration
elle joue sur le côté finalement
gouvernement technocratique qui se
succèdent sans le vrai peuple et ça le
met elle le met vraiment enseigne contre
vous en particulier contre Mario Draghi
évidemment elle le fait parce que c'est
son discours typique pour bagnat contre
les stablishment contre tout ça mais
évidemment c'est un discours qui a gagné
aux États-Unis avec Trump il a gagné en
Hongrie avec Orban mais par exemple en
France n'a pas gagné son discours en
Allemagne ce discours n'a pas gagné
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'on a des
chances dans les derniers jours dans
lesquels les gens les citoyens vont
penser à leur futur alors portefeuille
vous savez dans les sondages que vous
citiez qui donne aujourd'hui en tête
fratel real
il y a aussi un 42% des électeurs qui se
disent un décès qui n'ont pas des signes
qui ont décidé
jusqu'à maintenant de de s'abstenir et
ils sont en
pour le moment ils ont grandi des
électeurs là une campagne électorale
très très confuse c'est pour ça que nous
parlons assez électeurs là et nous
pensons pouvoir en une partie importante
alors il y a la question de l'Ukraine
aussi elle se dit atlantiste et
soutenant justement des sanctions par
rapport à l'Ukraine mais elle est en
coalition avec Salvini toujours Matteo
Salvini qui lui est beaucoup plus pro
russe est-ce qu'il y aurait il peut y
avoir une rupture diplomatique
sa position la position de George
germeloni est très proche de celle du
gouvernement polonais atlantisme d'un
côté et attentif atlantisme nettement
exercé et eurocepticisme exercer là
aussi d'une façon hélas très nette
mais dans sa coalition en plus que ça et
là Savigny qui sont qui ont toujours
exprimé des positions très très
timide vers l'aide à l'Ukraine et en
fait très proche de Poutine et de la
Russie sur les sanctions sur tous les
aspects liés à la guerre voilà c'est un
des points sur lesquels nous serions
très préoccupés d'une percée de la
droite en Italie aussi pour les
conséquences que ça aurait sur la guerre
en Ukraine et sur la position russe le
premier
qui serait content le soir de 25
septembre une victoire éventuelle de la
droite en Italie serait
utile la dernière Poutine je pense que
ce serait une piètre nouvelle je pense
que ce serait très négatif mais lui il
serait très content c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles nous nous
battons pour éviter tout ça alors vous
parlez justement de ce cha
pitre de la vie chère en Europe et en
particulier du gaz avec le discours sur
l'état de lune qui s'est tenu mercredi
devant le Parlement européen les
Européens et Bauche une taxe sur les
surprofis des entreprises énergétiques
et puis tente de plafonner les prix du
gaz aussi pour finalement leur
concitoyens est-ce que cette crise là
elle est bien gérée au niveau de
l'Europe
cette crise a été très bien jurée sur le
positionnement dès le début le 24
février l'Europe a bien choisi de quel
côté se mettre et nous aussi nous étions
là et on a été le grand parti italien le
plus pro européen antivirus et en faveur
de l'Ukraine évidemment le grand
problème est lié au conséquences en
termes de coût de l'énergie de cette
crise et c'est sur ces conséquences que
la droite italienne est en train de
tirer un avantage parce que les peurs et
souffle sur les peurs c'est pour ça que
il faut absolument que l'Europe ne
traîne pas il faut absolument que
l'Europe prenne des décisions le plus
rapidement que possible pour aider les
familles les foyers pour aider les
entreprises à résister à ces montées du
prix du gaz et de l'énergie il faut
mettre un toit au prix au niveau
européen il faut séparer le prix du gaz
et du prix de l'énergie produite avec
les renouvelables il faut une politique
européenne donc c'est le moment
d'ajouter à ce qui était très bien fait
contre la Russie en faveur de l'Ukraine
de faire quelque chose de très important
pour aider les entreprises et les
citoyens les familles européennes
résister à cette montée des prix de
l'énergie alors vous avez mentionné le
score historique d'une autre extrême
droite celle de Suède et parmi les
dossiers internationaux à traiter pour
la Suède ce petit pays il n'empêche sa
candidature historique à l'OTAN à
l'Alliance atlantique et puis la
présidence tournante de l'Union
européenne au 1er janvier là encore
l'extrême droite au pouvoir en Suède ça
pourrait changer des choses pour
l'Europe
je pense que c'est une autre mauvaise
nouvelle qu'on a reçu pendant les
derniers temps je pense que c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle car la Suède a joué un
rôle très important
l'actuel gouvernement le gouvernement
qui gérait les affaires jusqu'à
maintenant et évidemment avoir un
gouvernement mener par l'extrême droite
en Suède nous ramène à des souvenirs
très préoccupants c'est pour ça que moi
je pense vraiment que il faut contrer
cette montée de l'extrême droite on va
le faire on est en train de le faire en
Italie avec nos propositions sur la
santé publique sur le travail sur les
grandes questions au droit liés au lois
civils liés à la défense de
l'environnement la lutte contre le
changement climatique la droite
italienne est totalement négationniste
sur les sujets environnementaux ce
serait là aussi un énorme problème pour
l'Italie et pour l'Europe merci Anne
ricoletta d'avoir été en notre compagnie
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis vous
restez avec nous et nous allons recevoir
ma camarade de Public Sénat pour
débriefer le grand exercice d'urzula
devant le Parlement européen son fameux
discours sur l'état de l'Union c'est
tout de suite en compagnie de redécuter
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour notre grand
débat avec pour but de débriefer le
grand oral de rentrer d'Ursula Vendée à
la présidente de la Commission
européenne une heure de discours sur
l'état de l'Union à Strasbourg mercredi
devant les euros députés
il divulguait son programme pour l'année
à venir habillé aux couleurs de
l'Ukraine la chef de l'exécutif a
affirmé son soutien indéfectible aux
Ukrainiens aux côtés d'ailleurs de la
première dame alors grande réforme de
l'énergie soutient à la démocratie
modification des règles de gouvernance
économique ambition climatique
solidarité intergénérationnelle
Ursula vanderallen a mis en valeur l'ADN
des Européens et leurs capacité à réagir
vite aux crises quand ils sont unis or
nous sommes à la croisée des chemins
avec la montée des extrêmes et des
populismes sur fond d'hyperinflation et
de grognes sociales alors mention Très
Bien ou mention passable alors nous
poserons la question depuis Strasbourg à
2 euros Mariza Mathias député européenne
portugaise de la gauche la gauche qui a
plutôt chahuté la présidente et se
positionne dans l'opposition à
l'allemande soutenue par les trois
grands partis ppeux à droite socialiste
et au centre Rio Europe et rignaux
Europe c'est d'ailleurs votre partie
Fabienne Keller euro député vous
française ancienne mère de Strasbourg
vous avez forcément été plutôt conquise
non ah oui plutôt très bien si je peux
me permettre une présidente
Ursula funderlion très libéré très je
l'ai trouvé très très présente
physiquement avec olana zelenska qui
était présente depuis la veille à
Strasbourg avec laquelle visiblement
elle avait passé du temps
pleinement
consciente enfin chargé de cette mission
de l'Europe de soutenir le crâne mais
aussi d'être un grand espace souverain
qui protège les Européens face au défi
du monde défi en termes de guerre mais
aussi des filles
de souveraineté sur le plan industriel
volonté aussi de protéger les plus
fragiles elle a parlé sur le thème de
l'énergie du soutien aux personnes qui
subissaient la crise comme elle a évoqué
les possibilités de ressources du côté
des entreprises qui gagnaient beaucoup
d'argent grâce à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie alors justement vous parlez de
la guerre en Ukraine nous allons tout de
suite écouter Ursula van Darlen un
extrait de son discours où elle affiche
sa détermination face à Poutine
c'est une guerre économique une guerre
contre nos valeurs une guerre contre
notre avenir
c'est l'autocratie contre la démocratie
et je me tiens d'ici devant vous
convaincu qu'avec le courage et la
solidarité nécessaire Poutine tombera et
l'Ukraine et l'Europe
Mariza Mathias on l'entend est-ce que
vous avez été convaincu par Ursula
vanderleyen chef de guerre on pourrait
dire bien sûr le soutien européen le
peuple ukrainien c'est très important et
je crois que c'est aussi une des
dimensions
fondamentales de son discours aussi pour
les mesures vers les plafonnement les
ont des recettes des entreprises qui
gagnent beaucoup d'argent dans ce
moment-là à cause de l'entreprise de
l'énergie je crois que ce sont des
bonnes nouvelles je pense même avec
quelques retards mais ce sont des bonnes
nouvelles d'un autre côté je suis pas
d'accord quand la présidente parle de
comme elle a dit de redécouvrir et
découvrir l'esprit de Maastricht ça veut
dire de rentrer encore dans les
pakistanité croissance quand nous savons
que c'est pas le bon moment je crois que
nous avons déjà bien sûr que cette règle
elle fonctionne pas et pour moi c'est
vraiment une surprise qu'on a ce genre
de discours dans un moment que la
présidente elle-même a dit qu'il y a
encore un risque réception économique
alors justement beaucoup beaucoup
d'annonces sur l'économie on a senti que
cette présidente elle était passionnée
d'économie toujours annoncé des mesures
d'urgence en particulier vous l'avez dit
Fabienne Keller face à la crise
énergétique et une réforme globale
peut-être des prix de l'électricité
est-ce que les Européens vont percevoir
très vite en effet à travers elle une
Europe qui protège
alors il est clair que elle en a dessiné
les grandes lignes elle a évoqué l'idée
d'une régulation du marché de
l'électricité européenne ce marché pour
l'instant est extrêmement fractionné
entre les États qui chacun régule au
niveau national l'idée d'être solidaire
c'est à dire mieux interconnecté mais
aussi d'avoir une maîtrise de la
production de la distribution et des
prix avec des prix pour les personnes
fragiles des prix pour l'ensemble des
citoyens puis des prix pour les
entreprises
électro-intensifs ou PME donc une
volonté sur ce secteur de l'énergie au
fond où l'Europe est très peu intégrée
aujourd'hui dans l'énergie les
politiques sont très largement
nationales d'avoir une vraie vision
comme souvent en Europe c'est une crise
qui déclenche une volonté partagée
d'être plus efficace dans cette
solidarité dans cette puisque nous
sommes complémentaires nous avons une
réalité énergétique assez différente par
exemple des sources de renouvelables qui
sont différents suivant les États
membres beaucoup d'hydraulique beaucoup
plus de soleil dans les pays du Sud pour
dire les choses simplement du vent du
côté de la mer pour autant fait bien une
galère la député enfin Ursula l'année
dernière n'a pas convaincu tout le monde
la députée française du groupe de Mariza
Mattias la gauche Manon Aubry a brandi
une facture de 2300 € d'électricité on
va voir l'image d'ailleurs exactement et
la présidente
au Kremlin histoire de rappeler quel est
le vrai coupable je voudrais peut-être
avoir à la réaction de Mariza Mathias à
cet échange entre Manon Aubry qui est de
votre bord la gauche et aussi
l'avant-dernière le vrai coupable c'est
le Kremlin
il y a une responsabilité de Kremlin
bien sûr parce que tu les problèmes que
nous avons eu déjà sont agréés à cause
de la guerre et à cause de l'imposition
de Monsieur Poutine ça je crois qu'on
peut pas discuter mais c'est aussi vrai
on peut pas dire le contraire qui avant
la guerre et nous étions déjà dans une
situation d'infraction des prix très
août pour l'énergie nous avons déjà des
problèmes des propositions depuis
octobre 2021 il avait été c'est que nous
sommes obligés à attendre 11 mois pour
avoir par exemple des mesures comme
lesquelles la madame vendre Layal a
présenté hier et dans ce cas là bien sûr
la guerre est un facteur l'invasion
criminelle le facteur que ne facilite
pas notre vie mais on peut pas dire que
ça a commencé juste après la guerre il a
il y a une histoire avant la guerre et
les mesures arrivent juste presque un an
après alors autre grand point du
discours Fabienne Keller elle met en
garde elle met en place pardon un pacte
de défense de la démocratie pour lutter
contre la désinformation importée de
l'étranger mais aussi protéger l'État de
droit au sein de l'Union à la elle a pas
osé prononcer le mot Hongrie ni Pologne
et ce qu'on doit croire à cette
détermination d'Ursula de suspendre les
subventions s'il le faut alors moi je
suis très heureuse qu'elle est cité
explicitement même si comme vous le
rappelez elle a pas dit les noms des
deux pays sous article 7 mais elle a
marqué sa détermination le Parlement est
en effet très attentif nous avons eu
plusieurs débats à ce sujet pour que ne
soit pas accordé le plan de relance à la
Hongrie qui est un pays sans aucune
liberté de la presse et donc la justice
complètement dépendante du gouvernement
avec un système de corruption autour de
Victor qui est inadmissible en Europe
aujourd'hui la Hongrie pourrait pas
rentrer dans l'Union européenne parce
qu'elle assure pas les principes de
l'État de droit il en est de même pour
la Pologne ou le plan de relance a été
approuvé dans son principe mais des
clauses sur l'indépendance de la justice
sont toujours par remplis nous sommes
extrêmement vigilants parce que c'est en
fait le fonctionnement de toute l'Europe
qui est en cause nous nous faisons
confiance et pour cela nous avons besoin
que la séparation entre l'exécutif le
législatif et la justice qui juge de
l'application de la loi soit assurée et
c'est la liberté de la presse qui
garantit une bonne information de tous
et donc aussi un bon information de de
la justice c'est ce qui évite
l'arbitraire en marquant sa volonté elle
rappelle les valeurs fondamentales qui
sont aujourd'hui quand même fragilisées
par la Hongrie et la Pologne et
peut-être bientôt malheureusement remise
en cause en Suède et en Italie ce pacte
de défense de la dém cette fois-ci il
naîtrait également pour faire face au
régime autocratique qui inonde qui nous
inonde de fake news Russie en tête
Mariza Mathias un pacte de défense de la
démocratie face on va dire au régime
autocratique là comme la Russie ça
paraît dérisoires ça vous convaincre
alors j'ai interrogé la présidente du
Parlement européen Roberta mezzola sur
cet exercice de discours sur l'état de
l'Union 2022 très positif selon elle
mais elle insiste sur les autres sujets
on écoute
c'était au discours je pense avec
optimisme avec forte c'était fort en
soutien de l'Ukraine en commençant
finalement la décision sur la convention
de photos de l'Europe de la venue de
l'Europe en fait en faisant une
MPC sur sur le climat la situation dans
de l'énergie le soutien vers
l'entreprise qui sont aussi petits mais
aussi une
un point focus sur le jeunesse et sur
les étudiants vers elle insiste sur le
climat Mariza Matthia après un été
douloureux avec d'ailleurs une
solidarité européenne face aux incendies
est-ce que l'Union européenne façon
Vendée à leion mais vraiment le pied sur
l'accélérateur dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement ou au contraire un peu sur
le frein pour parer finalement au plus
pressé énergétique
mais je crois que dans les derniers mois
nous avons pris des mesures européennes
que vraiment
sont pas en ligne avec l'accord de Paris
mais même avec un accord plus en argile
de lutte contre les changements
climatiques et vraiment je pense que ça
c'est un problème et nous devons faire
de plus et malheureusement comme je
disais le parcours qu'on a fait le
dernier mois c'est pas dans la bonne
direction et c'est bon qu'on peut
insister que la crise climatique est là
nous avons pas seulement de solidarité
mais nous avons pas nous avons besoin
des mesures concrètes et nous parlons
d'une énergie il faut dire aussi je
pense qu'il y a toujours une résistance
européenne pour avoir des vrais
infrastructures des vraies connexions
entre les pays je suis du portugaise
nous sommes dans une île et énergétique
et bien sûr qu'il y a une certaine
responsabilité aussi de Monsieur Macron
qui ne veulent pas des connexions é
classique avec la pénicile
ibérique mais il y a toujours des choses
qu'on nous devons faire ensemble
Fabienne Keller la présidente de la
commission annoncé de nouvelles idées
pour la gouvernance économique et qui
devrait arriver dès le mois d'octobre
c'est le retour à l'esprit du traité de
Maastricht c'est un retour à
l'orthodoxie budgétaire vous pensez à ce
que c'est c'est nécessaire est-ce que
c'est adéquat en introduction marie-isa
Mathias celle qui était de ça
alors c'est c'est bien sûr un sujet
important notre stabilité budgétaire la
crise covid a conduit tous les États
membres à faire des dépenses
exceptionnelles pour maintenir
d'abord la situation des entreprises des
fragilisées par la crise et aussi pour
épauler des concitoyens qui pouvaient
perdant leur emploi tomber dans la
pauvreté donc tous les budgets ont connu
des déficits importants d'où l'idée de
retrouver une forme d'équilibre de
stabilité les conditions dans lesquelles
sera tout cela sera discuté dépend aussi
de l'évolution des prix de l'énergie et
de l'inflation revenir à ça c'était un
peu étonnant qu'elle revienne à des
références peut-être un peu plus plus
traditionnellement orthodoxe alors que
on
a une situation en fait inconnue jusque
là notamment en lien avec l'inflation
remonter des taux d'intérêt qui est en
cours mais elle a équilibré son discours
en soutenant vous êtes opposé au retour
mais en tout cas il faut la réinventer
il faut il faut une
philosophie de rigueur budget enfin de
gestion budgétaire saine plutôt mais
celle-ci ne peut pas s'appuyer sur des
critères anciens qui ont 30 ans ma
Street il y a 30 ans
il nous faut définir ce qui semble
efficace pour encourager à une gestion
saine des finances publiques parce qu'on
y a tous intérêt mais sans fragiliser la
reprise économique on a quand même
rattraper des 20-21 toute la
décroissance de 20 20 c'est
extraordinaire en 2008 on a mis 10 ans à
rattraper donc on a une situation de
l'emploi qui est très bonne globalement
en Europe on a ce sujet maintenant de
l'énergie qui est un vrai choc externe
il faut adapter les nouveaux critères
économiques à cette situation qui est
complètement différente d'il y a trois
décennies mais trouver aussi un accord
entre nous pour une bonne gestion Maryse
amathia pour conclure troisième littoral
de Ursula vanderleyen est-ce qu'elle
parvient à exister en une commission
géopolitique qu'elle appelait de ses
vœux
si vous me permettre je voudrais aussi
comment faire un commentaire sur les
règles économiques du pacte stabilité et
croissance parce que je crois que nous
avons pris une leçon pas seulement de la
crise panique mais aussi dans la crise
économique qui financière et je crois
que cette lésion est très claire les
règles de masse riches ne fonctionnent
pas et c'est pourquoi nous avons eu
besoin des suspendre le pack stabilisé
stabilité croissance pendant l'actualité
et
j'ai été vraiment surprise avec
l'annonce de la présidente de la
commission parce que et même
contradictoire dans les discours qu'elle
parle de la possibilité d'avoir une
récession et en même temps dit que nous
devons déjà partir un autre foi pour des
règles qui ne fonctionnent pas et que
vraiment mais une cause la croissance
économique et la capacité de l'Union
européenne sortir de cette crise alors
c'est bien on a qui a réconcilié sur ce
plateau le centre et la gauche radicale
sur la question de de ne plus pouvoir
regarder voir en couleur ce pacte de
stabilité merci à toutes les deux
d'avoir participé à ce débat merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi vous restez sur
nos antennes France 24 et publicitaire
[Musique]